mit m way jedem und alles wusste zu
buch.ch und bol.ch sind sandra und
danken ghana bis kanada im traum vom
großen bauernhof einziges ganze vermögen
steckt
aber darauf wird zum finanziellen
desaster
also nicht neu tag und nacht sind die
beiden auch
wie gott ihn erhöht ich gab swatch
kameramann und renault
die herbe zieht auf der farm eingeprägt
als schwierig
außerdem hatte ghanas hat sich alles
verändert
der hof ist weg
sandra hat karl lueger gemüse durch
und gedanken der doktorarbeit der
baumaschine
ihren traum platzt oder handy beide
endlich die freiheit wunde muss
eigentlich suchten
[Musik]
kanada ist das lieblings tief der
schweizer auswanderer hektar landschaft
und die mittel
aber wer darüber wie leben und die rufe
sie in kanada zu spüren über
ich bin weg zum betrachten der natur
noch viel krasser erlebte tarif jetzt
2009 sind sandra und danken ghana
ausgewandert und ihre form eines härte
zurück macht aber ganz neu anfangen
sie sind die kilometer
[Musik]
land break verstreut die südlich über
zwei fahrstunden südlich von calgary
busse in schöner landschaft ein visa und
piste führt nicht zusammen
für kanadische verhältnisse bedarf gut
erschlossen
richtig dann brach das glück von duncan
bedanken freut mich sehr monate
fortgeschrieben so brachte einfach wie
lange brauchten mehrheit
doch ein gebrochener hand die landschaft
noch nie so schön deutscher berühren
dafür dass das mindert lieferung ja
schon meistens wenn du deine erzähler
wir haben auf diese und viele andere ob
nicht als la péri endlich sind sie fünf
jahre lang monitore
es war es durch eine dusche mobbing
[Gelächter]
von sumpf und mücke nannte das ehepaar
gar noch nichts als es in kanada eine
farm kaufte das land 130 400 77 jahre
lang haben danken und sandra jeden
franken auf die seite gelegt für ihren
traum einen bauernhof in kanada irland
direkt am lake manitoba ist über 1000
fußballfelder groß hier wollen garros
von der mutterkuhhaltung leben das heißt
sie in kälber auf um sie später
möglichst teuer wieder zu verkaufen
zuerst müssen sie 100 eigene mutterkühe
erwerben
duncan bietet eifrig mit doch die preise
steigen immer höher
meist zu hoch für danken und sandra
[Musik]
sie kaufen weniger kühe als geplant
aber da war
am gleichen abend noch treffen sie ein
die ersten sechs mutterkühe alle tragen
sie ein kalb in sich wichtige
startkapital für sandra und danken
dafür komisch und lässt sich nicht
so herzig zu müssen dass sie sind
[Musik]
als ehemalige büroangestellte hat sandra
keinerlei erfahrungen in der
landwirtschaft danken ist auf einem
bauernhof aufgewachsen aber trotz seiner
kenntnisse kommt er hier nicht zur ruhe
ob sommer oder winter einmal bringt er
17 kälber in einer nacht zur welt dem
kalb geht es schlecht und der sonst so
sanft mit gedanken kommt an seine
grenzen
[Musik]
der druck auf banken ist groß die herde
muss wachsen jedes kalb zählt
duncans anstrengungen werden gelobt das
kalb erholt sich
vom wohlergehen der tiere hängt die
zukunft von garros ab
[Musik]
bringen wir es die mama
die mutter des kalbes ist keine fahne
zwischen 140
[Musik]
ja ja
ja
große stars
[Musik]
doch auf das paar warten noch größere
prüfungen fast den ganzen sommer regnet
ist das weideland wird zum sumpf dass
holland ist unter wasser dann muss das
foto und teuer bei anderen bauern kaufen
garros haben bisher nur geld ausgegeben
und noch nichts verdient auf ihrem konto
herrscht bald apple
doch der bleibt aus die fraktion wird
zum finanziellen desaster machtlos
müssen die kanus zu sehen die die bieter
viel zu tiefe preise aushandeln den
großen zahltag hatten sie sich erhofft
doch stattdessen muss sandra nun einen
nebenjob annehmen
die beiden machen fast alles richtig
kommen aber auf keinen grünen zweig
desillusioniert geben garros auf sie
wollen den hof verkaufen aber in kanada
bleiben
ich stelle mir vor wenn alles für
klappen dass man in kanada bis schönsten
das hüsli hand teilzeitjob genug für den
schotten wirklich was sagen kann im
winter auf reichmann können sie die
adware - wo du einfach sieht für
häuslebauer knies nach einem fluss wo
entweder laxere für alle drin heizens
mit griechischer fliegen fliegen fische
hobby könnte die unterstützung vom land
aber nicht ran ortschaft wunder könnt
ihr freunde unterhalten und nationalpark
oder so skigebiet dem spiel die wende
[Musik]
doch bis tatsächlich umziehen dauert es
noch geschlagene vier jahren
[Musik]
vier jahre zum becher an unglück ruhig
ghanas ein schier unglaubliches erlebt
und fangen dort alberta kilometer weiter
weg von ulla sie hoffe dass da alles
besser wird als das irgend geht damit
mit äußerer entscheidet dass man sich
also noch ein anderes lied bewohner ja
das mikrofon meine tochter mir auch
sicher eindruck sie ja ja ja
15 stunden pickup mitgefahren und
irgendwo ramires 50 stunden also
schrieben dass jedes hinderten ihn wie
lerne gamer und hier ein
ich habe es meinen arsch oder hayek
fühlt ich fühle mich mehr daheim aus
smart oben
ja ich sage so lange zeit text ist ja
also ich sehe ich momentan aber nicht
ruft eine ältere landschaft mäßig und
auch von der lieth hört sich das alles
verändert unser land kann daran später
lebt ja stellen führen könne sich hoch
und esszimmer daher ziemlich schnell die
ganz ganz hoch ist macht sie ja also wir
kaufen nicht so gut wie der schweiz und
der von tim hortons adressen dankbar ist
natürlich alle was ist passiert dass ihr
weg gegangen sind weil bisher ja denn da
nach essien ich nochmal ganz 47 strich
man hat es gescheppert hat 2010 und
haben absolut seriös und dann 2011
si mro überschwemmt worden und habe dann
den hof vom markt präsenten hofmann
alles wunderbar es ist passiert und dann
zeigt mir gar noch die unglaubliche
bilder des gerätes wiener
naturkatastrophe im frühling 2011 hat
zweige regen und schneeschmelze dann
auch gestartet akkus hoch war vorbei und
regierung etwas notfallmässig abgeleitet
auch in lake manitoba speck von der gans
ihren ganzen hof liegt am ufer vor dem
see
24 gestiegen
breitet sich aus und landschaft tus
stusie quadratkilometer sind unbrauchbar
kwk kraft für die für ghana katastrophe
über ein jahr hat bis also wieder
abgeflossen ist
aber wenn es passiert riesen stress und
daher weil er kommt es oft auf volle
geschwindigkeit verlor aber einfach der
ganze stress und des wissens nach noch
schlimmerer durch süße beschwerden mehr
ein forscher fritz maasch zum glück
nicht so viel besser machen es möglich
psychisch das alles verarbeiten
besonderheit das zdf nur über
überschwänglich gerät aber das hat mich
derart aufgeregt dass er zurecht kam
irgendwann bist so negative insgesamt
die halbe millionen investiert werden
wieviel hendrix rektor gemacht da müssen
wir mit dem gleichen der vorläufe römer
brachten und das ist darum werkleitungen
man wirklich alles klappt und man nicht
rückwärts machen
das war ideal müssen an einem punkt der
aktion nahmen verlusten auf der
plattform oder andere einfach das ist
sie eben immer weiter machen aber ich
bereue nicht dass man das gemacht hätte
ich glaube das wäre immer der traum
blieb sie als eigene aufzuhören um mich
ein trotzdem schwammig und trotzdem ich
würde bedingen
zum schluss können sind gesteht sie und
sagte mir hat es geschafft mehr weiter
machen aber ich wirklich nicht dass sie
entweder machen also nicht
40 wenn ich könnte ihn aber nicht davon
abhängig sein team verdient wirklich das
ganze jahreslohn innerhalb viertelstunde
die intel bekommt ihnen durchaus nur
hoffen dass 270 off charakter
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gemüse aber auch viel gelernt
wie neue hust zur hetzt warenfluss nur
ein zitat morgen erklärt dass da
wirklich überschwänglich sich
lockere die 92 hektar sandra und danken
hentschel 100 bäume pflanzt das gefühl
dass sie da auch wirklich an der wurzel
[Musik]
drei riesige lange winter und endlich
wieder zeit für sie
zum anderen und seines audi punkt auf
ihrer wunschliste sind erfüllt
[Musik]
nur die sehnsucht noch ein leben als
farmer die schwüre tim duncan mit
eigener für die gegend lebt oder
landwirtschaft mit windenergie und im
tourismus
[Musik]
das freizeit ferien und freunde der gala
diner herbst gelten
[Musik]
zum glück hat bedanken schnell und
jobwunder ich suri knox in ihre
baustellen jetzt ist wieder hergestellt
und mühe seine eigene schiff im oktober
hätte zwar selber im stall baut aber
richtig auf den banken sehr
abwechslungsreich machen von
betonfundament wandbilder dach zu dach
ab lag mit gleich material natürlich
fast ein auto und jeden tag etwas neues
ich mein krieg galt je nach wenn dabei
bin ich sowieso mehr quandt cie
wer lieber frust mein geschlecht zweiter
aber
der handwerker rückt der vintage kanada
und jobcentern einmal danken spontane
chance und er packt sie in einen
arbeitskollegen danken nicht erzählt was
ihm ihre lebensgeschichte er ist amerika
aufgewachsen und eigentlich nur zum
schlafen ins schwitzen und dort hast du
die liebe seines lebens gefunden
ja stimmt meine eltern hatten angst ich
würde mich dort verlieben und bleiben
und genau das tat ich was ich nichts
mehr freiheit im hof schafft wo alles
gehört oder wenn man als angestellter
schafft und dafür hab ich ja freiheit
oder selbstständig ashton natürlich
finalshow deutschen entscheider was du
machst wann und wie aber wer mit
kirschen ihr freizeitkarte treffer womit
gesperrten hof bayerischen hier weg
gegangen da als eingestellt da nicht
natürliches frei wochenend ferienzeit um
für mich an ich fühle mich viel freier
jetzt als angestellte wieder der farmer
danken ich stehe für immer erledigt oder
er schon mal den wagen nur japan
verstärkt als erledigt dabei bleibt in
mein herz liebte
bedanken ich handwerklich ein
alleskönner arbeit mit dem hemeraner
macht ihm spaß
aber eine andere maschine wäre ihm
glaubt noch linie freut machen
ja ich hatte mein tag
drei kilometer weg von aus leeds steht
pintscher krieg mit vier ist der größte
ort und sein traum von der region
dort hat sandra ihren job gefunden mit
ihr ein
[Musik]
es gibt grafiken an officer hat zwei
verwilderte katzen eingefangen
wir müssen hier rein kann die nicht zu
den anderen stücken
[Musik]
ich denke ja sehr
jetzt haben wir zwei junge wilde die hat
er jetzt gefangen weil bewusst setze
reklamiert das land machen und das
putzen
dieses mal ist dann warten wir zum
tierarzt ramona lied das man sich
einbringen
für den empfang und dann war das beste
was man sich eine gastieren wieder
adoptiere ich habe auch schwierig mit zu
bilden
die sind doch gar nicht alle quanta
branche so lang bis sich langsam sind
dass man sich eine streicheln buche
[Musik]
schlägt zum putzen und ich habe mich da
so ein glamouröser job ich habe mit der
kanzlerin spieler der linken hand sucht
der straße gefunden hätten der profis am
auto kürt und ist sie am berger hang zu
unserm haus gefunden aber ausgesetzt
[Musik]
viel verdient zahlt 40 dollar pro stunde
als der kanadische mindestlohn bislang
zum leben
große ansprüche hätten sie bei genügt
wenn gold sandra normal zu der beiden
streunen der psychologe vormittag
verbracht worden sind und reklamiert
sind ja nicht wenig aber die klinik
zu viele verbote
und findet für alle dass die ja
eigentlich ebene bahn-spitze längen und
barak in der türkei hatte schleifen
die finden alles heim des opera zum hype
mit la bonne klar mit anderen katzen
das sind jetzt zwar immer noch nicht
fertig kämpft sind die blieben also
jetzt so viel wie unter danken erschafft
einen anderen ort ist das ein vorteil
oder nachteil
ich finde es ein vorteil wenn wir sind
beide hände bis anders tour und damit
sollte heißen haben wieder biss neues zu
erzählen und farbe stufe 20 stunden
jeden tag zusammen und ist in euskirchen
oder wenn du schaffst sammeln und es
geschafft sein und den weg übers
geschafft und jetzt hat er blut klebe
ich kann andere lied das macht sie das
leaks lecks richtig glücklich
ja also ich genieße es einfach weil ich
habe nie ruhe wachsen kommentierte und
ein mal schlechte tage später mit der
kanzlerin ja eigentlich niemand
zugetraut schwarz gefahren
sandra muss man sie nicht räumen will
ich schlafe aus liebe zu merken dass sie
gar nicht zu ihm passen
ihre bilanz mit 219 innen überholen und
eine ist bereit für das neueste high
life bridge stadion zwischen dir
handlich und spannend und die türen
dafür hat sein adoptieren scheinriese
hilfreich
[Musik]
ein ruhiger 4 roddick ist für zander und
dankend neuland früher noch hätte sich
gedanken jetzt vermutlich sorgen um
michael dick macht druck ließ die beiden
wenige momente
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen kurz grad hilft mit
dem kanadischen glück wie für viele
gehört auch wieder dankend fischerorte
oben bediente zu ihrem weg zum
lieblingsplatz gardinen an hus
wieder überschwänglich egal ob sie hof
liefert keine hechtfischer dominik
altfeld
und der besser zeit wirklich schräg weg
das ist ein fisch
[Musik]
ja
also 3
damit nimmt das sind größer aussehen wie
laufen vor wasserinsekten
übt wird keine richtige arbeit danken
gott aber enid omerovic einflussreich
der natur das ist für mich schön
schwierig wenn du die ganze tat mit fran
schon einige von ihnen schönste fischer
erlebnisse wohne ich eigentlich nicht
unbedingt fischfang ist einfach stimmig
von der natur am fluss sie ja das ist
für mich fast therapeutischen watzka als
jetzt
komischerweise demnach gar nicht nur
große für alle fans sind 30 auf der
neuen kraft macht haben
dann nimmt das ufer der mund und
kontrolliert ob es nur ganz kurz
vielleicht die sekunden 2 und dann
spritzte es wieder größer meint einen
moment der hacke netz setzte der
afghanische weg also eine art tanz mit
der natur finden
[Musik]
rouven land aber mit völlig abgeschieden
für sich aber auch mit kontakt sondern
auch genau das und genuss für ihren
zweiten start kanada gesucht
gar nicht aufladen das dorf
die kamera ist dieses für die tankstelle
laden und schuhe
das machen nicht viele im dorf
[Musik]
sind wir jetzt nicht damit kilometer
der el alami gehört dazu seien sie gut
stimme bricht
laptops 250 280
dies ist general store der dorfladen und
treffpunkt
sind noch ganz heiß recht gut ganz
frisch gebacken
wissen alle wo durch sind und von der
umliegende quartier roma sind und
besteht häufig deshalb auch am
compostela briefträger die post verteilt
das immer so zentrale anlaufstelle
robbies homophonen griff sondern auch
eine andere wichtige institution im dorf
wie man sport oder gesehen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bosch 43 nachrichten aus der schweiz
ich habe gesagt er hoffe so auto aber
dass sich den sommer dazu werden wir der
natürlichen golfplatz auch bisher schon
das fortlaufende schweiz man hat jetzt
hat der kanadisch passend ist natürlich
beides mittelland könnte zwei bis zu
bedanken mit dem amerikanischen passen
thematisch und für mich schweizer
kanadier schwankt sie nur vierte liga
gültig sind keine eigene ist der wunsch
nach sie macht mich krank sind dass ich
mir das nochmal würde vielleicht einfach
schön gesagt
und so verteilt moly zu der familie an
darunter sind tierheim mit knut
eigentlich nur für das wochenende aber
danken hätten teilnehmer wählen zu gehen
[Musik]
neues live qualität und wo verbringt mit
ihrem land zum beispiel ihre freiwillige
für die lustigen vom mikro mandantin
wurde für wer brigade vorlandbrücke
nicht nur mit ihrer a mit dem rohstoff
oder lockere gruppe and gals schnell
freundschaft geschlossen
sie sägen so herzlich empfangen wurde
dass sie die gemeinschaft bisweilen
zurück statt dieser nacht ruft welt
bringen geht es darum jetzt für gedanken
und sandra andré jährige alle zwei
wochen mit der engine 14
[Musik]
meistens ganz nett koblenz löschen
sondern sie rückte unfällen mit wild die
joh
wir sind die besten 15 unterwegs spitze
wenig gefahr weniger abonnieren
großbrand michels von der dvd macht
probleme
deshalb so verschwendet dass lastwagen
vom wind um kiptum dahin es natürlich
verkehr muss erhalten um während das
lokal taxis entnommen aus zwei lastwagen
[Musik]
dieser tag und nacht wird allerdings
kleiner stärke gewinnt sondern absperr
regel von wasser umgeben
[Musik]
das große brandgefahr im sommer und die
gemeinde sind abhängig von freiwillige
führer irgendwann wird zum waldbrand
lage meinte scott parker lang nicht im
wasser reagieren wenn man auch noch mal
das ist die sache aber das ist nicht
dürfen wir dass jeder losgemacht gegen
der browns muss organisiert ablaufen
müssen die dann nicht auf vorderste
frauen präsentiert die neue gewässer wo
man mit halver sagte dazu muss am
schluchsee oder sogar später nach
uwe riehs lehrplans sirene normal laufe
[Musik]
noch ist der ruhige landschaft verstauen
immer besser
das seien da nie ziert
was zu viel verlangt break dir wenn es
unbedingt nur zeigen
mit schelte vom kanadischen winter
sandra m höhe kann und darum gehen sie
unter danken schon bald das buch auf
südamerika
die punkt vor ihrer wunschliste
gott so billig
nein
wollt ihr eigentlich egal ob die ares
zur verschönerung windrose es formen und
so was sind eigentlich richtig sind die
letzten amerikaner auch schweizer
kanadier schweiz kanadier bei das ist
dann kritisch sich die motive sind für
die comet in kanada sicher ja also ich
hab es nicht vorstellen schweiz karla
babica und obwohl der bezogene herrsche
und die wohlfühl cash was macht den
heimat und musste daher angst hsv ist
meines fußes schlosses autoschlüssel
sind im alter das kontakt zu dem
wohlfühl effekt ist dass ein minister
freizeitmöglichkeiten könnte die
umgebung wohnen möglich müsse und auch
in den ferien einen ford ka und wissen
dass wir durchkommen schönsten
vorstellen was unachtsamen werden wieder
zuzüglich haben wir das aber nicht
vorstellen dass ich jetzt schon weiß
23 der spanier traf es neues zu
probieren
bliebe oder wm-woche sicheres einzig
sandra und danken ghana und ihres glücks
kanada erst im zweiten anlauf gefunden
[Musik]
vom ländliche canada goose necks woche
oft dubai die faszinierende stadt am
persischen golf familie ausgewandert
der vertreter hätten job als pilotkunde
durch trick jahre und celina sind in
englischen mutter monika die heizung
recht beklagen aber jetzt finde ich
monika und ihre töchter sind so peter
schwarz
nicht verwirklichen wir bauen sich
monika der neue zukunft durch und
landete sie hat es nichts die der ersten
rede nach der schweiz zu bezwingen bevor
spezial in einer woche
[Musik]
ziel der sie gut in form
mit m way jeden und alles wusste zur
buch.ch